so what I want to do is just sort of
explore this idea a little bit further
and let's just have some examples right
so if we had a couple of actual vectors
defined so I've got an actual a and an
actual B what could we do with this
right well I want us to explore two
different things we could do it with it
firstly uh let's just find the angle
let's make this part
um one find the angle
between
uh A and B
by the way if I was being a more
technically accurate I would say find
the acute angle because of course you
could do the the
um reflex angle as well but usually we
want the smallest one right it's very
very similar to in complex numbers like
we were talking about what's it called
by the way when you look for an angle to
a complex number it's got another a name
do you remember what that is
argument very good and then when it
comes to the argument right
um any complex number on the plane you
can think of an infinite number of
angles you can just keep on going round
and round around the Argon diagram but
there's one angle one argument that is
the smallest one right remember what
that's called starts with a P
it's the oh it's been a little while hey
it's the it's the principal argument I
guess principle in this context being
like the main one now it's quite funny
when you look at that especially as a
teacher I'm like yes I've had principal
arguments in the past not this kind
though anyway this is the same idea
right we're looking for the smallest
angle because why use a big angle if a
small angle will do the same job
so in this case uh let's begin in some
ways it's a fairly routine thing to do
right where you can just uh Trot out the
formula cos theta equals and I'm going
to start Computing the dot product on
the top and I'm going to need the
magnitudes on the bottom okay so just to
make it easier for you I'm just going to
highlight here are X components here our
y components and here are our Z
components so can you guys tell me what
am I going to do to start Computing that
dot product
yep perfect so I've got my color code
here so I'm not that you have to do this
but just to make it very very obvious
you multiply your X components that
gives you negative three in this case
your y components give you a big fat
zero and then what are my Z components
give us
that's plus eight okay fantastic so
there's the numerator dot products not
that hard to calculate and then on the
denominator I now independently need to
work out each of the magnitudes now have
a look carefully because I didn't choose
these numbers by accident right you've
got three zero negative four when I
Square to do Pythagoras what am I going
to get the square root of what
yep so all right 25 which gives you five
so there's the 16 and the nine combining
there and then if you have a look at the
um the B Vector right when you square
you're going to get
one four and four so yeah that gives you
that gives you 9. now just again I keep
saying this right and trying to point
out because I want you to realize it's
deliberate right
um I I chose these vectors because they
would be easy to work with
um I've gotten integer values out of
this right which uh not just sorry
integer values I've gotten Square values
out of it right
um how did I do that though
um you might recognize when it comes to
a uh three and four of course they are
two-thirds of a Pythagorean Triad right
Pythagorean triple so three four five
um one two and two
are actually not a Pythagorean Triad
right but when you combine them with
three what you get is there's four
numbers the sum of the squares the first
three give you the last one so it's
still from Pythagoras but there's four
things not three so what would you call
that it's a Pythagorean
hmm uh it's not a it's not a a triple
anymore it's a it's a quadruple I guess
or a quad makes me think of leg muscles
anyway one two two and three and there's
just like with Pythagorean Triads
there's an infinite number of these
right so anyway you can go ahead and
find those uh what we can do here is of
course we can simplify so I've got five
over five times three
so that gives us a third okay uh what do
I do this
very good so cos R Theta is equal to a
third so to find the acute Theta uh
thankfully I can just go to my
calculator I can pop in cos inverse um
what did you guys get I should um I've
got a number already ready but have you
guys got it there with your calculator
is oh yeah so my question was going to
be okay
radians yeah great question so um it's
funny right because in this question uh
because I just I just wrote it
um I haven't defined Us in theater and
sorry in degrees or radians um I'll give
you an answer in a second but my
question to all of you is
um what might be a reason we want
degrees or radians like what skews you
using in One Direction or the other
um I usually find uh like when we were
doing the uh complex numbers you know
the rate the whole piece of ratings was
um important yes yes that's right you'll
okay so so you've noticed um in complex
numbers we exclusively in fact I'd be
very surprised if you find anywhere
where they don't do this um and I'll
give you the reason why in a second we
pretty much exclusively use radians in
complex numbers but let's
for a minute because it's not just you
extension 2 students who know about
radians
um you you're the only ones you know
about complex numbers but if you went to
an extension one student or even an
advanced student they learn what radians
are again I'm going to pose the question
why am I in an advanced or an extension
one student choose say for example
radians over degrees have you if you've
never been told this before I'll happily
tell you but does anyone know what's
going on there
the circumference of the stuff okay so
it's it's to do with um yes this this
circularity um when you when you look
and you're like I say okay can I what
should I divide this option to should I
go 360 degrees or should I go 2 pi going
with radians makes the calculation of
things like the circumference or or an
arc like a part of the circumference
much easier okay
um this is all true right however I
might point out in in a question like
this uh or indeed even in complex
numbers you don't necessarily have
circles explicitly coming up anywhere
you can you can create them but you
don't have to let me give you the real
fundamental reason and um hopefully it
might explain why we do it in um in
complex numbers
the reason why we care about radians the
most within the context of this course
is because of this result
um tell me uh we're in we're in theaters
at the moment so I'm differentiating
with respect to Theta what is the
derivative of sine feeder can you guys
tell me what that is
cos Theta right but guess what I know
this is shocking but it's only cos Theta
in radians uh the the the gradient
function of sine Theta is only cos Theta
in radians because if you talk
um a version of like what would the
graph look like right if I went from
naught to 2 pi in radians okay this is
what it looks like and if you go ahead
and you actually you know take a ruler
to make a tangent and if you were to you
know go ahead and work out say for
example the origin that's a nice
convenient point right
um what's the gradient there the
gradient is equal to the gradient would
at the origin would be equal to one but
only if you were in radians if you were
in degrees
2 pi is what is that 6.28 right so
actually in degrees your um your graph
hasn't gotten very far at all it's only
got like six degrees right so it's
something like if I was drawing sine it
would look like this it would be super
flat right I have to go all the way to
360 Degrees to get a full cycle of cyan
now if you have a look at this blue line
here that I've drawn right the gradient
there is clearly not going to be the
same it's much it's much lower it's much
flatter okay it's only in radians in
that scale that you get a nice gradient
and if you recall like that m equals one
that gives you this and then you say oh
the gradient here is zero and then you
only get this cos graph if you're in
radians okay now you might be saying Mr
Wu how do we get to calculus three we're
in vectors right
um well number one Mrs Iles you did ask
the question about degrees and radians
I'm about to answer it uh do you
remember in complex numbers this comes
to your answer Sean why we care about
trigonometry in complex numbers it's
because we know the rectangular form of
a complex number we could say it is X
Plus i y but there's two other forms
right what are the two other forms that
you've got
okay yep so CIS is um it's an
abbreviation for cause plus eyesight yep
just just for completeness what's the
other one by the way
comments the oiler thing which is 80 to
the online
yep that's right and don't forget
there's um these are modulus and so
that's we have R for the radius right
um and actually I've given you just a
unit one anyway so let me just fix up
that bit over here that should have an R
out the front as well now the key thing
is it's it's the relationship between
the
um trigonometric form and the
exponential form the relationship
between them is calculus and if you've
not seen the proof for like why you can
get from an exponential to this cause
and sign thing it's quite bizarre
actually I remember looking at it and
being like what's going on here it's
calculus is what's going on underneath
um if you're like I've got like a ton of
videos about this I'll link it in the
teens Channel if um you'd like me to
find it more easily for you but to bring
this all the way back right we care
about radians because they let us do
calculus basically we trigonometric
functions and because complex numbers is
built all the stuff in complex numbers
is built off of calculus even if you
don't see it it's there in the
background you need to use radians to do
that now finally sorry it was a deep
rabbit hole we can come back to here
right in vectors
are we doing any calculus with these
vectors
yeah
yeah that's exactly right it's like
we're not actually interested in do
these angles change does the vector get
longer shorter Etc over time calculus is
the mathematics of change in the same
way that like probability is the
mathematics of uncertainty and geometry
is the mathematics of measurement right
there's no calculus really in how we
learn vectors
um at least not in this topic so for
that reason this is a very long way of
saying actually it doesn't matter
whether you're in degrees or radians
um no probably I could have just told
you that out the gate but I do want you
to have a like one of the things I hated
back in school at University for that
matter is when I asked the question and
I just got told a rule and I never knew
what the rule was about like why is it
this sometimes and sometimes you don't
care in this context
angles uh sorry can be in degrees or
radians because we are sort of not doing
any uh differentiation or integration or
things like that so I expect by now your
calculators have told you something
right uh were you in degrees or radians
just out of curiosity
degrees okay what'd you get
uh 70.5 yeah me too so 70.5 degrees I
suppose I should say that's to one
decimal place
um and I'm satisfied with that right I
don't know Mrs ask did you get in
radians I guess it's like what would
that be
okay no problem
I mean a radian is something
seven degrees so this would be like I
don't know 1.2 ish but you know I'm
quite fine with it uh maybe actually I
will say uh one thing that might skew
you towards uh being in degrees rather
than Radiance if they don't ask you is
we did ask for an acute angle right so
just to check like oh is that acute like
I I know that 70 degrees is acute
without even thinking about it whereas
when I'm in radians I have to remember
wait what's an acute angle in radians
again uh
Pi is a straight angle so a right angle
is pi on two that's 1.57 so there's just
a bit more thinking involved but I'm
satisfied with this
does that make sense how are you doing
so far